to the model how do you decide what
isn't isn't misinformation
how do you decide what is true you
actually have open ai's internal factual
performance Benchmark there's a lot of
cool benchmarks here uh how do you build
a benchmark for what is true
what is truth
say I'm Alvin like math is true and the
origin of covid is not agreed upon as
ground truth
those are the two things and then
there's stuff that's like
certainly not true
um
but between that first and second
milestone
there's a lot of disagreement what do
you look for what can a not even just
now but in the future
where can
we as a human civilization look for look
to for truth
what do you know is true
what are you absolutely certain is true
[Laughter]
I have uh generally epistemic humility
about everything and I'm freaked out by
how little I know and understand about
the world so that even that question is
terrifying to me
um
there's a bucket of things that are
have a high degree of Truth in this
which is where you would put math a lot
of math yeah
can't be certain but it's good enough
for like this conversation we can say
math is true yeah I mean some uh quite a
bit of physics uh this historical facts
uh maybe dates of when a war started
there's a lot of details about military
conflict inside inside history uh of
course you start to get you know just
read blitzed which is this oh I want to
read that yeah
it was really good it's uh it gives a
theory of Nazi Germany and Hitler that
so much can be described about Hitler
and a lot of the upper echelon of Nazi
Germany through the excessive use of
drugs
and amphetamines right and amphetamines
but also other stuff but it's just just
a lot and uh you know that's really
interesting it's really compelling and
for some reason like whoa that's really
that would explain a lot that's somehow
really sticky it's an idea that's sticky
and then you read a lot of criticism of
that book later by historians that
that's actually there's a lot of cherry
picking going on and it's actually is
using the fact that that's a very sticky
explanation there's something about
humans that likes a very simple
narrative describe everything sure for
sure and then yeah too much amphetamines
cause the war is like a great
even if not true simple explanation that
feels
satisfying and excuses a lot of other
probably much darker human truths yeah
the the military strategy uh employed uh
the atrocities the speeches
uh the just the way hit the was as a
human being the way Hitler was as a
leader all that could be explained to
this one little lens and it's like well
that's if you say that's true that's a
really compelling truth so maybe truth
is in one sense is defined as a thing
that is a collective intelligence we
kind of all our brains are sticking to
and we're like yeah yeah yeah a bunch of
a bunch of ants get together and like
yeah this is it I was gonna say sheep
but there's a connotation to that but
yeah it's hard to know what is true and
I think when constructing a GPT like
model you have to contend with that
I think a lot of the answers you know
like if you ask
gpt4
just to stick on the same topic did
covert leak from a lab yeah I expect you
would get a reasonable answer there's a
really good answer yeah
it laid out the the hypotheses the
the interesting thing it said
which is refreshing to hear is there's
something like there's very little
evidence for either hypothesis direct
evidence which isn't is important to
State a lot of people kind of the reason
why there's a lot of uh uncertainty
and a lot of debate is because there's
not strong physical evidence of either
heavy circumstantial evidence on either
side and then the other is more like
biological theoretical kind of
um discussion and I think the answer the
nuanced answer the GPT provider was
actually
pretty damn good and also importantly
saying that there is uncertainty just
just the fact that there is uncertainty
as a statement was really powerful man
remember when like the social media
platforms were Banning people for
saying it was a lab leak
yeah
that's really humbling The Humbling the
overreach of power in censorship
but that that you're the more powerful
GPT becomes the more pressure they'll be
to censor
we have a different set of challenges
faced by the previous generation of
companies which is
people talk about
Free Speech issues with GPT but it's not
quite the same thing it's not like this
is a computer program what it's a lot to
say and it's also not about the mass
spread and the challenges that I think
may have made the Twitter and Facebook
and others have struggled with so much
so we will have very significant
challenges but they'll be very new and
very different
and maybe yeah very new very different
it's a good way to put it there could be
truths that are harmful in their truth
uh I don't know group difference is an
IQ there you go
scientific work that once spoken might
do more harm
and you ask GPT that should GPT tell you
there's books written on this that are
rigorous scientifically but are very
uncomfortable and probably not
productive in any sense but maybe are as
people are arguing all kinds of sides of
this and a lot of them have hate in
their heart and so what do you do with
that if there's a large number of people
who hate others
but I actually
um citing scientific studies what do you
do with that what does gbt do with that
what is the priority of gpg to decrease
the amount of hate in the world
is it up to GPT is it up to us humans I
think we as openai have responsibility
for
the tools we put out into the world I
think the tools themselves can't have
responsibility in the way I understand
it wow see you
you carry some of that burden for
responsibility all of us all of us at
the company
so there could be harm caused by this
tool and there will be harm caused by
this tool um
there will be harm there will be
tremendous benefits but you know tools
do wonderful good and real bad
and we will minimize the bad and
maximize the good they have to carry the
the weight of that